[Music]
clap
clap you jerks
clap happy friday everyone
jesse waters is here no no no no don't
change it don't change it it's going to
be great trust me
[Laughter]
so finally justice has arrived after all
the rampant crime the smash and grabs
the subway shovers the brutal random
murders of young women our leaders are
finally doing something about it
late wednesday night a statue of
theodore roosevelt that's a president
cat was removed after standing in front
of the american museum of natural
history for more than 80 years yeah
instead of removing the vagrants who've
been defecating doing drugs and
assaulting people go after the inanimate
stiff
that'll make life better but hey
teddy was evil those glasses that
mustache he probably wore those as a
disguise while he was beating a people
of color
so get lost you jerk and take your
racist horse with you
and what a heroic feat to rid us of
teddy or at least his statue so typical
of libs to pick on something that can't
hit back by the way the removal cost the
city 2 million bucks so where they
sending teddy to private school antifa
could have done it for free with ropes
with cnn looking the other way hell cat
would have done it for two sixers
the beer not the players
but
but where else would you like that money
to go
for more policing in the subways or the
streets where crime is rampant shut up
you bigot did you know the statue was
deemed so offensive they covered it with
a massive orange tarp the same one brian
stelter uses as a towel in the steam
room
the monument's now in a library in north
dakota so like all residents fleeing new
york to florida it's probably safer in
the new york post they quote one of
teddy's descendants theodore roosevelt
the fifth
who cheered the removal saying the
statue is being relocated to a place
where its composition can be
re-contextualized
to facilitate difficult complex and
inclusive discussions
well thank you you pretentious
if teddy were alive he'd dress you up
like a white rhino and chase you through
central park with a 12 gauge now if you
think i care about these statues i don't
i'm not into statues except for the
nudes
and even then the security at the museum
keeps a pretty good eye on me
but this is part of a larger problem
americans care about crime
they don't care about statues any more
than they care about trans bathrooms or
pronouns but someone does it's our
craven leaders who are under the thumb
of a tiny woke mob
this as crime explodes in every city run
by libs we hear the tragedies every day
but they don't get the outrage you saw
over statues in those heady days of the
george floyd riots when statues were
dropping like jeffrey tubin's pants
during a zoom call never gets old now
many were of confederate soldiers
toppled by protesters but it didn't stop
there and even the city leaders joined
in
just as one guy predicted
in the proud tradition of america's
great leaders
from george washington please don't take
his statute down please
please
to lincoln to teddy roosevelt i see they
want to take teddy roosevelt's
down too
they're trying to figure out why they
don't know they're trying to take away
our culture they're trying to take away
our history and our weak leaders
they do it overnight these things have
been there for 150 years for a hundred
years
weak
weak
people
we didn't deserve him
protesters tore down statues of
anti-slavery heroes as well as statues
of governors they removed monuments
honoring citizens who fought in the
union army they trashed statues of the
missionary universe sarah
that's my high school that my school is
named after him and they better leave my
statue alone i'm riding tom brady on
horseback
of course columbus was removed in
chicago by lori lightweight black kids
are getting shot by other black kids and
she's like let's get that dead italian
out of here if only we had a visual aid
to shed some light on these misplaced
priorities
thank you all for coming i'll keep this
brief before turning the mic over to the
cnn sex crimes unit
after two years of exhausting all of our
resources we have finally apprehended
the man who has caused our community so
much pain and sadness his reign of
terror is over and we can finally feel
safe again
now i'll give you one last look at the
son of a [ __ ] before we put him away
for good
we also called his accomplice
i believe they call that the getaway
but in conclusion him
and the horse he rode in on oh
and if you called the department in the
past couple of months about robberies
and murders i promise you we will return
your phone call we just got to work out
some staffing issues
thank you
that's a police bust
so as crime spun out of control our
media saw progress in this pointless
purge abe lincoln statue was toppled in
portland i guess they're siding with
john wilkes booth
both thomas jefferson and george
washington were also knocked down in
that town then they destroyed the city
of course there's no correlation there
andrew jackson in mississippi francis
scott key in san francisco ulysses s
grant also toppled an sf probably to be
replaced by a giant bronze pile of human
feces
even frederick douglass wasn't safe he
was torn down in rochester new york
like brian kilmeade's fleas that's a
head scratcher
the virgin mary decapitated in tennessee
jesus christ decapitated in miami
probably because it needed a nose job
gandhi even god he was vandalized in
davis california and we all remember
what a jerk he was
and yet the media and our politicians
thought it was progress that this would
help cities and help people but like
what disney did to star wars they
destroyed something and replaced it with
something worse
the rest of us though we knew this was
an excuse for mayhem a gateway for more
than just destroying statues and what
came next businesses and police
precincts destroyed nothing was sacred
and when looting is defended as a good
thing society is as backwards as
crisscross's pants there's a reference
wow it's the broken window theory on
meth you let society go to hell and it
quite literally goes to hell we have
criminals released from prison to commit
more crime on new york subways l.a bus
stations high-end furniture stores
they'll stab you because they're as
soulless and cold as the statues being
torn down and yet even now the statues
are still a priority because fake virtue
signaling is easier than dealing with
real suffering and politicians were just
more terrified of the mob than they were
of you bill de blasio ted wheeler jacob
fry if they were any more yellow they'd
be on the simpsons
and now people are dying in part because
leaders felt a piece of stone was more
harmful than a dude with a knife when
the truth is sometimes the statue is the
only thing between you and the dude with
a knife so now the only safe statue
is the one in the white house
until they make a real one of them then
they'll tear it down in a heartbeat
let's welcome
tonight's guest
when he's feeling romantic he runs his
fingers through his own hair co-host of
the five and host of the brand new jesse
waters primetime
jessie waters
smattering of applause
he comes up with more plots than a grave
digger up in the air author walter kern
the irony of him being a writer for
cheers is that nobody knows his name
tv writer and producer rob long
and speaking of that everyone at the bar
yells cheers when she finally leaves fox
news contributor cat tip
[Applause]
because she drinks yeah jesse yes i you
know it's a serious issue crime but if
there was a statue of you put up
how long after it went up would it take
for people to tear it down well it
depends if it was a nude statue
um i don't think i'm going to surprise
anybody when i say that i am not that
big of a fan of art no
but i do appreciate statues because
you're right i do want to be a statue
one day and in all seriousness we have
when i say we i mean my assistant johnny
yeah has has called the mayor of
scranton wait where did you get your
start allentown allentown yeah allentown
and we are in active negotiations with
the mayor to erect a statue of you are
you kidding me i swear now bro about
this months ago yes see thank you thank
you all right so we are now deciding
whether this is going to be on public or
private land and we've actually
found a price point it's ten thousand
dollars right because it's going to be
to scale yeah
and it's and it's actually smaller than
you think because you're going to be
depicted sitting down okay because we
know you get uncomfortable when you
stand that is true uh where there's
going to be an unveiling ceremony you
guys are all invited to it and we expect
it to be toppled yes and um
and you're eventually we may have to
take it down because you'll have
canceled yourself and brought great
shame on all of us
and then we'll just put it in a basement
somewhere you know i didn't expect that
as an answer but i'm very excited over
this
i believe you yeah didn't i tell you
literally talked to me about this months
ago
i can't wait who pays for this that's
also a negotiation
i bet
i bet i can get a rich lonely old man to
pay for it rob
well again only if it's nude and you're
seated i need that
that's what i think and it has to has to
move in some way like i'm thinking like
the great moments with mr lincoln i kind
of want you to stand up and do a
monologue just like the robot i would
like the chair to be made of glass
so people can just
yeah well anyway we gotta get that low
yeah all right well i'm gonna leave you
be i've drooled over the happiness of
this uh walter how i know you're you're
on uh you've got uh some dental issues
right now oh yeah i cracked a tooth on
the way to new york city and so i've got
both novocaine and uh a pharmaceutical i
won't name so i don't get robbed on the
way out of the building
um robbed by either me or cat yeah yeah
don't worry about the criminals i'm
waiting for you i know what you got so
it's walter kern on chain today yes yeah
so what's your take on this on this uh
crime versus statute okay i've got three
points number one
i'm not for the removal of statues in
general but if there's one statue i
would remove it might be teddy roosevelt
with an indian and a black dude helping
him on his horse
you know so so i might make an exception
for that one number two
who judges statues guilty yeah who holds
the trial right so i think the
constitution should afford statues the
right to a fair trial that's a great
point and i think they should be judged
by a jury of their peer
other statutes yes
i think other statues should decide if
you know george washington has to go or
something and i think the statue that's
on trial should have the right to remain
silent
which shouldn't be hard because it's a
statue yes yeah
well done my friend well prepared you
know not bad for a guy who's on oxy i
know
do i do some of my best thinking on that
if you've watched the five
it makes me rethink the whole sackler
family thing maybe they are our heroes
maybe
misunderstood rob i've been saying that
to you all alone
that's really true actually i love the
wilford brimley beard by the way thank
you thank you i'm like uh you know he he
he was not as old as he yes as he looked
no he wasn't and that's what i'm going
for yeah so where do you are you i mean
i don't see this to me isn't about
statues it's about how politicians can
only focus at one thing at a time and so
as crime is going on over here
everybody's going after inanimate
objects while people are getting killed
well yeah i mean first of all i'm still
a little ten thou ten grand for what
like what is it
yes bronze i think he bronze really he
doesn't deserve broadband aluminum foil
ball but you kind of shape that i can do
it for 50 bucks yeah then i think you
know
put the money somewhere else no i would
say about about the stat
it is a long standing tradition for all
politicians easy stuff first right so
it's easy to pull down the statue and
then you can do that and you can buy
yourself a month yeah while everything
gets worse or everything gets better
magically by itself
i don't really care about the statues
actually maybe it's time to put have
different heroes like i don't know it's
not a work of art really it's just a
kind of a commemoration so we should
just all decide who our you know our new
heroes are mine would be
the guy who like put the cheese in the
crust
oh cheesy crust but why should the horse
have to suffer that is true the horse
did nothing wrong exactly did nothing
wrong yeah that's interesting
who are our modern heroes right now uh
real housewives yeah you know i think
kat you might have some ideas on the
kind of statues that would matter most
to the young people the young demo given
that you're uh you know you're under 40
just about just about
i'm significantly under 40.
that's okay though because i'm so wise
and accomplished
people i'm very accomplished and smart
so people forget like there's no way she
could be that young yeah so i i
understand it's like the reverse will i
get that yeah i get that all the time
like really she's so successful how is
she not 50.
my advice don't grow a beard
i can't i've been trying
i don't step whenever this happens i
always just like find out these statues
exist yeah i don't i don't notice the
statues i've always been to the museum
of modern art no i'm just always i went
but i was on my phone the whole time
me too
it's true you know what it is it's the
streisand effect on statues
right like the strike you don't know
something until i'm like oh that's that
oh wow yeah i didn't even know that was
there what that was i mean like i'm sure
i've been around it all these statues
but i just also want to again be clear
that he's not joking because
you when you hosted for greg when you
took your day off for your birthday and
like you had me you had some questions
for me about hosting the show and you
were very much like while i have you
here
and then you tried to leave and that was
in september glad to see it's still in
motion it's still there's been some
supply chain issues
uh we're working on this i don't think
allentown is that going to be that
supportive of me
i don't think well that's why we're
negotiating the private plot as opposed
to the public first he's got to buy the
land
yes all right well we solved nothing
this was completely derailed by my
statue hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else